Paulie how are you my friend I'm good
I'm good man great to have get to be on
the show man thank you all right listen
I I know you've been all over the place
I'm sure you probably can't leave your
house without being asked about what the
heck went on with these sparring matches
I've heard you on podcast I've heard you
all over the place we go way back sort
of you're from BK I'm from Manhattan
huge fan what the hell went on when you
sparred Conor McGregor and before you
even answer that when you were when you
were a rural champion all your years in
the ring is a boxer what is the proper
etiquette of a sparring partner
basically break that down first um well
you know what a sparring partner when I
was a sheriff you should little fighter
you know you bring in several different
sparring partners in the camp and you
break it down into different rounds so
that you are getting the back some um
work oh you're you usually get a few
rounds a day out of each of them so so
let's say for one day you're boxing
around you'll probably use two of them
when you do four rounds each you know
and and that will uh you know keep them
keep keep them coming in fresh and their
way you out a little more
you know while they're a little fresh so
that way you'll never actually have to
put one particular guy in for a lot of
rounds because you know you're going to
be in better shape because you're the
one training to the fight he's not and
so usually use that's why you bring in
several different foreign partners so
they stay fresh and you don't know where
they're testing you not just tactically
but also all mentally as well now when
you had sparring partner years in boxing
it somehow my use in boxing position
concern Mike I mean you know I've been a
part of many gym Wars and whatnot so as
a gym Wars the whole thing with the gym
was it wasn't really an issue for me at
all you know that was something I
probably would expect every time I did
into a championship camp okay that makes
sense now have you ever sort of like as
far as sparring what was your
expectations what did you think you were
walking into with with with Conor
McGregor like how did that even come
about all his team reached out to me um
they uh they wanted me to work with with
them and you know I mean I was kind of
taken aback a little bit because you
know usually not you never hear you
never hear of anybody up you never hear
of anybody calling up a retired fighter
you know so I thought it was a little
bit a little bit odd but when I found
out that he had an old boxing trainer in
camp you know a lot of people thought of
mentioning that to me and they said you
know maybe he wants you in there just
for some tactical stuff because you know
he doesn't have a legit boxing trainer
in camp he just has a lot of the team
that he's had around with mixed martial
arts so you know I thought that you know
maybe that's a possibility
you know it's oh maybe it's one of the
maybe it's one of the possibilities you
know so I said you know I I we made a
deal and really negotiate I got set in
several different interviews you know I
said I said that's all you know I took
the first offer they gave me I didn't
really ask for any accommodations in
particular or anything I just I was fine
with the accommodations they had for
sparring partners and whatnot and uh and
I was that was fine with me you know so
I mean now that's how we kind of agreed
on everything and then the song we moved
on to eventually it was time for me to
come out to town and you know that's how
I thought things I'm going to point out
now all right this is Michael Rapaport
on line with Paulie Malignaggi two-time
world champion all caught up in the
middle of this drama do you feel like
you were sort of bamboozled and caught
off guard and sort of used in a way not
just yeah oh yeah I mean yeah I think at
the end of the day there was probably an
agenda um you know I didn't really see
myself walking into it because usually
don't see guys have an issue with
sparring partners you know usually have
a problem with a guy you fight them
right what you don't fight them or
sometimes I've seen guys with it they
don't fight them they'll want to give
them a payday they don't fight them you
know or you just take them in and you
fight them um the whole sparring thing
um I don't know I've never actually
heard of that in my life you know I'm on
my own video editing is you know if
you're gonna if you're gonna dislike
somebody they may you know let's go with
a to town so let's get it on mounting or
like I said if you're a big shot and you
want to be a big shot in our guard you
don't fight when you don't give them a
payday I mean it's one of the other
really yeah I've never heard of my life
of somebody having a disagreement and
say oh let's spar remember not that
don't get me wrong Jim what has happen
all the time
right especially the old-school recent
gym where I came up out of the wild-card
gym where I was training for a lot of
years Jim what's happened all the time
and rivalry developed inside the gym all
the time
but as far as your now liking somebody
from the outside and then not you from
the outside and then like this okay
let's spar I mean that that is some of
them I mean I I mean I don't even I
don't know how much I can talk I'm on
the show not much I concur so what now
but that is some other don't do it what
she did I've seen in my life you know
yeah no I get it or somebody you don't
set up sparring with somebody don't like
you know the goal of the big that idea
is Big O you know you're just not gonna
do enough damage to them you know you're
gonna go at it but you're not gonna do
enough damage them like I am no I got it
you know the thing that offended me
Paulie as a boxing fan because I've
never rooted for Floyd before just
because of his style and some of his
personal stuff but I'm rooting for
boxing in this case and I think this
whole thing that Connor is doing is a
sham and I think it was classless if you
guys fought 12 rounds and the only
photos that exist are him maybe or maybe
not connecting on a punch and you maybe
or maybe not getting knocked down or
quite possibly getting pushed down by a
guy who doesn't add a box but knows how
to you know MMA and fight and be overly
aggressive that's the thing that if
enemy if you guys fought 12 rounds
where's the pictures of you punching him
in the face
where's the kitchen I mean it was only
the COG reverse for him I mean of course
different form around you know we got
couple pictures like that I mean you see
that doesn't really have much much of
much of what you want to call it much
material you know I mean control around
in both guys are always in the shot you
know and your photographers are there
just for him if that's all he has then
you know you can even kind of use your
mind and say with sparring one you know
there was little good you know it was a
good session I mean I started picking up
the pace as it went along and I started
getting the better of him but it was a
good session I mean you know he came out
strong and we worked back and forth it
was a you know it was kind of jockeying
for position I thought I take control
and I took control of any kind of
goldish form you know so I mean it
wasn't it was the kind of sparring
session where at the end of it I was I
thought we had buried the hatchet you
know but this point out pretty good um
and I like I said I mean I I came in
better shape you know I came to camp
totally out of shape monk and I'm saying
like right I was far especially I had a
thought you know I haven't I had a
barely trained like I got the call
started training it has that swea
because I got the caller I sort of
training but then Lily they never got
back to me so I wasn't even sure I was
going you know I was like calm and if
you if your moral victory or if you want
to around the retired fighter barely
been in the gym I mean that meant god
bless you know but for a guy who's
supposed to be be able to achieve so
much I think I think at the end of the
day you're probably supposed to hold
yourself to a higher standard than that
or than this you know I mean beginning
sparring partners don't come in but he's
burning all the bridges you know I mean
I mean uh you know bringing fighters
don't easily quack the sparring partners
they have their own thing going on but I
think he's burning all the bridges he
did it so crisp in here didn't where he
tried to record and like set up a little
little photo album or himself a little
video images for himself where he can
dissect and edit the video and then then
here to ended up having the video the
full video and it looked bad it was a
peck on Connors face and then you know
he did this to me you know but the only
thing you learn from the many Internet
experience was to make sure everybody
check their phones and their cameras at
the door so nobody else can take a sneak
video of pic see if you're really in
this regard I mean like I said the first
time we did have been here then I guess
I didn't learn the lesson you know I
thought like I you know I was probably a
one-time thing for him and he learned
his lesson and I thought he did it twice
I mean after that happened with me Andre
Berto decided he wasn't communicating
bondrée but I was gonna meet up with him
for lunch for insertion he's gonna be in
Vegas and I spoke to him great stories
and he's like ain't going over there you
know he goes wrong so you know I I told
them I said Andre goes I told them I
said you know you're not gonna be
pointing that camera stuff for me you
know and he didn't like the answer in
Kongregate he didn't like the response
Connor gave him you know so it was like
well over like he didn't give him a
definitive no we won't have cameras you
know so the Andre was like man I'm not
going well knocked out you know so I was
like yeah I mean I don't blame you you
know so it kind of was kind of at that
situation where you know he kind of
burning all the bridges he's got like
you know he does foreign partners he's
got in camp and he's got one kid we know
who the final work will consider a
friend of mine he's a journeyman kind of
kid he's been with a lot of tough
fighters you know had some bad raps you
know a good young fighter I mean a good
other older fighter you know and then
he's got a young amateur kiddos you know
decent fighter um he's got time and army
guys you know you you're training for
the best fighter in the world you know I
don't know that for me we're gonna walk
away title at this point I mean I don't
know if he beat
stands idly Bighorn so you know I think
Mayweather stole championship or fighter
but you're finding you're getting our
defy one of the best fighters in the
world or maybe the best fighter of the
era I don't know people the best fighter
of the arrow right now but you've
definitely been the best fighter of his
era and you're getting ready to fight
him with that kind of sparring you know
and you can't even bring anybody else
who's sharp or a better anymore because
you kind of burned all your bridges I
don't care we can't purchase refugee
camps in general I'm on him I'm on the
full of Paulie Malignaggi two-time world
champion you said that when you sparred
Conor you hit him in the body and every
time you hit him in the body he
whimpered what did those whimper sound
like it was it sound like a head or was
it like of course it was it with Irish
brogue like can you give me a
description of the sound did it sound
like great like what did you sound like
he was being a like a violated he went
personal body you know I think
especially if he's getting fatigued a
little bit hit him to the bodies in a
whimper you know I'm not going we got it
said that I think one of his other
points had said that as well as Nate
Diaz had mentioned that as well um you
know I think body shots are not a common
theme in mixed martial arts
ah you know there's a bit of
debilitation to them there's a slow
debilitation that to them you know I
think you know these are the things that
he's learning a training camp you know
he's coming along I'm not gonna lie to
you he's coming along a little bit in
the time but I saw him there I think
he'd be a decent prospect but I think
you know you gotta you make these kind
of jumps in your career according to you
know the wins you get and you know you
don't just jump into these kind of
things but of course you know it's the
kind of situation where he's been so
successful of mixed martial arts that
you know this is curiosity to see if you
can bring this kind of success over the
boxing and so this in this uh this big
curiosity has generated this amount of
hype and whatnot and a lot of people
think you can do it you know no problem
here's a question this might but I mean
I know it's at the end of the day you
know you're going in a solid of course
we are we we we got we got 30 seconds
what is your prediction are you allowed
what are you allowed to say what do you
think how do you think quickly do you
think this fight is going to like really
pan out on August 26 was in your favor
for Mayweather I think it's an either
logical favorite o Connors young he's
got them with that youthful energy
a little bit of awkwardness can you make
that work for him I don't know you know
I think at the end of the day Mayweather
is legit favored for a reason I mean it
so you don't need ask me why me was this
the favorite I think even the oddsmakers
know why that's what it made it such a
heavy favor and whatnot
picanha has a legion of fans are they
ruling with the hard muscle in their
mind I mean we'll find out the 26th you
know but there's definitely a lot of
people that think harder to do this oh
well I'm not on the 26th you know I'll
get into more the more tactical to stuff
on the broadcast or supposed to you know
what might work and what might not work
and what not and why it will work or why
it won't work
and of course I'll leave that decision
I'm staying at home and once I give that
poor tactical breakdown
all right well Paulie listen I think
it's great of a boxer's you are you've
made it just as great as a boxing
analyst I'm glad you know Connors lucky
you kept it classy because in my book
out of all sports your top ten trash
talker of all time you've kept it classy
Brooklyn's in the house I appreciate you
calling in to the Rich Eisen show Paulie
Malignaggi and keep doing your thing and
I can't wait to see this thing unfold
and I'm going to be listening to you and
watching you on the 26 give all the
information and insight so thanks for
taking the time Paul II appreciate you
having me on the show Mike and all and I
keep a classy but album Brooklyn man
hold on I got a dirt bag today I'm gonna
call the dirt bag
absolutely absolutely Paulie I
appreciate it and again thanks for
calling in and thanks bye my man okay
Paulie Malignaggi the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you liked that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to